300 families over 1 000 orphans are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
assalamu alaikum brothers sisters and
dear friends hope you guys are well
inshaallah this is going to be a video
directed to our christian brothers and
sisters in humanity from muslims i'm
going to be watching a video of kanye
west of his new track called donda and
on that is his mother's name now with
this video it's quite controversial and
some people think there's some kind of
satanic ritual going on some say no it's
not he's even got marrying marine manson
in there as well which he's been
cancelled recently with some abuse
towards women or whatever it may be so
some people are speculating that kenya
invited him and the baby i don't know
whoever who he is um to show that you
know there is hope
don't lose hope in god but the whole
thing is a bit bizarre let's get
straight into it and watch the actual
music video um and see is this satanic
ritual what is satanic ritual is say the
satan work in a way where he makes
himself apparent or is he camouflaged
we're going to learn a few things israel
inshallah and we're going to give a
reminder from as muslims
why we believe there's a whole plot
twist to the whole thing let's get
straight into it
i mean as muslims that first name we
have no problem hallelujah praise be to
god we say alhamdulillah all praises
belong to allah god almighty so as
muslims we don't really have a problem
with that statement saying hallelujah in
that instant because we believe all
praises belong to allah
belong to the lord the lord of the whole
world the final mistake in which i've
done a bit of research this was kanye
west's home like makeshift home uh with
a
with a cross on it so as you guys see
there let's repeat that
again in the name of jesus now this is
where things get a bit bizarre and
strange why does that happen because at
the end of the day guys you can see here
this is a makeshift home i think this is
where he's in there and something very
strange happens when he's in the house
okay i don't know what message is trying
to give out but he is set on fire yeah
so he's on fire the whole room gets on
fire now to me i don't know how that is
a tribute to his mom and you've got
people for example in the very video um
going around um you know with his mom's
name written on them it's the whole
thing seems a bit bizarre and strange
you know if you look at it for example
you know why why are they doing that you
know and when they come to this kind of
stuff we believe in the on uh the the
unseen world the jinn and satan and
people that work with them yeah are
those who god or who they would ask them
to do specific things uh for specific
powers so i don't know if kanye west is
working with them i don't know if he's
been told if you do this and do that and
set yourself on fire and get this ritual
going on etc we would i don't know bring
show you your mom or you will see your
mom or you'll speak to your mom and we
know it won't be his mum yeah it would
be maybe someone seen as his mom it
could be satan so he might go to that
links because when people really miss
their loved ones and for kanye west his
mother was really close to him he might
go down that route so i don't know if
that's the case or not now let's go
with the thing that it is genuinely is
doing it for god almighty or his belief
and system whatever it may be
and he's genuinely doing that now
there's a few things that we need to
really really understand here we think
that for example satanic rituals or
worships happen in a way for example
that um it's it's it's the cross upside
down antichrist um it's satanic symbols
uh you know and there's different
different you know weird strange things
that happen satan doesn't really come to
you like that yeah and allah says in the
quran that satan took him over he said
oh allah i'm going to misguide them yeah
give me till the day of recompense the
day of judgment i'm going to misguide
them now satan is not going to come to
you and be like you know with this weird
signs you know of a goat etc star sign
upside down etc all this kind of stuff
here he's not going to come to you like
that he's going to come to you in a way
where he can
fool you into
accepting him because if christians are
muslim altogether and jews let's put us
all together here if we was to told if
we said okay this is a place of satan
worshippers are we all going to go there
no we're not why would we go there it's
clear-cut misguidance
satan doesn't work like that he will
come to and allah says he is an enemy
and take him as an enemy okay and one
that's really bizarre some people come
and say that
as muslims you know islam is satanic etc
it's from satan
i mean we
the whole quran is against satan so it
doesn't make sense it's about satan but
we are against satan so i want to say
something and i don't mean an offensive
way to any of my christian friends
watching this as well but i really want
you to think about what i'm about to say
to you yeah
is that satan will come to you in
camouflage and that camouflage could be
the cross now you might be offended i
don't want you to be offended i do not
do videos to offend you
but i need to tell you the reality from
how we see yeah
if you think about it if you go to
church and in church things are being
done that are displeasing to god yeah
that is there satan in camouflage
because what's happened is you are
associating partners to god jesus said
in the bible right he said hear o israel
our lord god is he said our lord god is
it your god he said our lord god
but one god yeah is one good okay now he
didn't see the father the son and holy
spirit he did not say that even in the
bible it says that jesus will say on
that day
many will come unto me and say lord lord
did we not prophesy in thy name and in
thy name cast out demons and jesus will
say get away from me i do not know you i
don't i don't know you who prophet says
in the name of jesus and who cast demons
at the name in the name of jesus muslims
jews
hindus sikhs or christians
guys
and we know what we're trying to say in
a nutshell guys is just imagine
if you guys seen that video where it
shows our planet to the whole universe
can you imagine the blasphemy that we
claim that god almighty you created the
heavens and the earth that is bigger
than that universe yes
came into that little speck of earth
it goes against its nature and it's the
greatest form of blasphemy so when we're
looking at satanic rituals and stuff
like that let's not go to kenny west's
video and set himself on fire and got
people going around and done all kind of
mad stuff weird stuff happening
let's look a bit closer to home
and that is exactly how satan operates
and i will end on that note satan
operates in that way that you will never
you will not
see it's coming and it might be the very
places that you go of worship where
you're praising hallelujah okay praise
be to god okay but hold on a second why
in jesus name why glorify jesus why make
jesus to be god that is the biggest form
of blasphemy that satan wants you to do
you got married
manson there and
they say that kanye west brought him
there to you know
the doors of
repentance and you know mercy of god is
always open well what mary manson did to
those women are disgusting and in islam
to violate the right to violate the
rights of women or whoever it may be is
very severe however to bring him closer
to something that he's going to be let's
say argument saying take jesus as his
lord and savior yeah is a bigger crime
you've took him from something which is
wrong wronging people which is wrong too
wrong in god almighty by claiming that
jesus is god and jesus freed himself for
that jesus never ever claimed divinity
and he always always praised god and
i'll leave you guys on that note guys um
that when it comes to satanic rituals
look a bit closer home don't think satan
is dumb he's not stupid shaytan is an
enemy and allah says in the quran
is one
he is self-sufficient he does not beget
nor is he begotten and there is nothing
like unto him
i'll leave that with you guys if you
want to read the quran learn more about
islam you can come visit speaker's
corner and see myself and my friends and
we can talk more i hope you guys benefit
from this video till next time assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh